haha the Joe Rogan experience you know
when it when it when it came to yang I
felt like here we a guy who I'm not a
big fan of you bi and that's a weird one
right they I think the way he put it
spoke more to me than the way anyone
else ever framed it and I actually felt
like he shouldn't have called it
universal basic income hmm when he
didn't he called the Freedom dividend
right yeah but it became you bi to so
many people that's why they went with it
yeah when you see you know Amazon Google
in these big companies becoming just
insane behemoths they can't you know
they can't be broken up they just absorb
an absorbent absorb and there's an
argument for some kind of dividend to
the American people for potentially what
they do outside of the United States
it's it's very complicated up not
economics I guess I'm not smart enough
to you know pretend like I know anything
about but you look at he brought the
example of Alaska they have the oil
drilling the people who live in Alaska I
get a portion of that revenue and those
profits that makes sense
you bi the way it's framed in general
makes very little sense and eventually I
think we're actually seeing now with the
government stimulus one of the biggest
pitfalls to it
do you hear there's a there's a story
they ran an NBC a woman her employees
were like in revolt because she acquired
a loan from the paycheck protection
program that insured their jobs meaning
they would receive less money because
under the cares Act they would have
received a bonus of $600 per week on top
of the salary they'd normally get they
actually preferred to have lost their
jobs so you have people who are
complaining that they're keeping their
jobs now so there's that's one instance
though there's a couple stories like
that but the challenge with just giving
people cash cash is the assumption that
the cash has inherent value when the
value of it is based upon what you can
get for it so one of the lessons I think
we learn now with the economy being shut
down is doctors and nurses got to work
you know that we need them on the front
line they're also getting paid what do
they use that money for pay their rent
buy food things like that where I think
we're facing food shortages if you can't
buy anything with the money what's the
point to take in the money I mean like
if you were given a choice
you're gonna work you're gonna go work
your job at a grocery store you're an
essential worker we're gonna pay you for
in a box your buddy
who isn't let me stop you right there
because the universal basic income was
not designed to deal with the pandemic
it was designed to deal with automation
which might have not stopped the supply
chain which has not stopped which
wouldn't have created food shortages
this is a sort of a unique situation so
you're comparing apples oranges you're
applying universal basic income to our
current situation which has nothing to
do with the reason why he wanted to
implement it in the first place he's
worried that automation is gonna take
away jobs he's right it will it probably
not well now consider this problem
though there will always be some kind of
essential work right yes what you tell
the essential worker when other people
are getting money and don't work that
you have no choice because you're
essential even in an automation system
so let's say every job but grosser but
hold on a second they're only getting a
small amount of money to stay alive you
would rather have a good job were you
getting paid well and have benefits and
all that other stuff
I think that's an assumption I see it is
an assumption basic income the real
problem there's a psychologist your
issue the real problem is the way human
beings work we need incentives we don't
yeah people don't just want to survive
and get a little check from the
government will be people be despondent
you know you you don't want to create
any united states of welfare like in an
all-encompassing thing where some you
know these programs that are in place
that automate all of the goods and
services they take some of that money
and give it back to the people because
no one can work like that's a that's a
depressing dystopian future I mean
that's a terrible place to live
you ever watch Battlestar Galactica yes
love GRC snowpiercer which that then you
talking about a new Battlestar Galactica
one what was snowpiercer which one was
that that's where Chris Evans is on a
train that travels around the world
because the world is frozen and only
that train has like it's a kind of a
weird premise but there's an episode of
but no no no no it's a movie I just
bring up two different bits of fiction
to you know make a point
oh yeah it's a futuristic movie it's
real weird who else is in it Chris a
captain right isn't it yeah I think I
did see that it's real weird yeah it's
kind of cool so they take kids from the
back from the poor cart and have them
work internally in the engine because
they have to move things around because
parts
missing if they don't everyone all human
life dies so they literally go in the
back and they take children away from
their families who scream and reject
this in Battlestar they had children who
were also taken for a similar reason to
work you had people who had no choice
but to work on the fuel processing ship
otherwise all of you many we wiped out
one of them thought about you know I'm a
huge fan of Star Trek The Next
Generation how do we get to a post
capitalism world where we still have
incentives but we're post Reno
post-scarcity the problem is in it as
we're in transition there will be jobs
that are essential which means one of
the one of the glimpses we get I
understand a pandemic is different but
we still see a glimpse of people who
have to work you know kind of
low-skilled boring tedious jobs like at
a grocery store while other people who
have higher skilled jobs are getting
their their needs met by the government
at least in terms of the cash so we're
we're here telling you know these people
who's talking about right now right
right so I understand it's a pandemic
it's very specific but we're getting a
glimpse of what happens when some people
are told your job is not essential so
we're gonna guarantee your food and
resources for the time being you are
clearly doing that though the solace is
effective I'm just I'm just saying that
as we move towards automation there will
still be jobs that are essential what do
we do how do we you know incentivize and
compensate make that worth the people
who have no choice but to keep working
while the rest of us don't I don't know
if it's a keep working while the rest of
us don't issue I think it's a problem of
jobs being phased out I think the real
problem is automation is gonna phase out
jobs it's not gonna be about what's
essential what's not essential I think
you're sort of applying pandemic
vernacular to it let's let's let's
remove the pandemic from it and let's
say you know right now one of the things
I looked at and we talked about this
little bit before I met a homeless guy
in Chicago and he worked at a job that
became obsolete
I set back about it yes I asked a
homeless guy how he became homeless when
I was when I was like 19 and he told me
that he had a job he worked there for
20-30 years as he got older his family
you know moved away lost contact is four
different times some of friends and
family had died when his company became
obsolete technology didn't matter
anymore he was cast out you know he had
nowhere to nowhere to work anymore and
his expertise was very specific so he
got a severance package
ran out he got unemployment that ran out
he got kicked out now he's homeless I
look at that and I say how do we make
sure that doesn't happen this guy should
not be punished simply because times
have changed but if you scale that up
you know and say it keeps happening at
every different sector eventually you'll
end up with 90% of the population saying
my needs will be taken care of and 10%
saying I still have to work whatever the
industry may be like that's a
transitional periods gonna be very
difficult we automate most jobs except
for some some people will still have to
work does anybody really think you're
gonna automate most jobs though I mean
there's so many jobs that can't be
motives automated yeah I don't think
that gotta be the I mean we're you're
talking about some weird sort of
futuristic Star Trek
yeah I don't think that's what we need
to be concerned with I think I think the
idea of universal basic income is
wonderful the idea that your your needs
are taken care of in terms of food and
housing and then everything else you got
to do on your own if if we're looking at
when we look at struggle right we look
at struggle like across the board can't
feed yourself can't put a roof over your
head can't would have the this is what
was attractive about universal basic
income to me what if we all agreed that
some semblance of dignity is a part of
being an American and then we will
provide you with food we would provide
you with housing everything else you
have to earn and that's
interesting that's interesting I like
that I like it but I don't know is it
people don't work well when they don't
have to exactly when people don't have
an incentive and the competition is
important
[Applause]